this is a production of Cornell
University
pleasure to be here thanks for the
invitation nice to see some familiar
faces happy to talk about my work I
usually spend most of my time doing it
and not much time talking about
summarizing it so this was a really good
exercise for me and sort of tying some
things together to give people who have
absolutely no idea what I've been doing
for the last 20 years a snapshot of one
particular area of my work as Tony said
and I'm very proud to say I almost feel
I've been around long enough to say I'm
one of those old-fashioned extension
scientists I really believe very
strongly in my commitment as an
extension specialist and you're going to
see that in my work I've had the
pleasure of course you can't avoid being
involved in basic research at some level
at this place and I've always had the
pleasure of being involved in that but
what I'm going to talk to you today
about is this intersection of systems
based research done at the landscape
level and changing people's behaviors
and using data to drive your education
programs and then further continue to
hone the research and education ideas
that you implement this is the
environment that I work in what we now
know as the urban ecosystem we've got
really nice terms for that type of
landscape now this is the particular
landscape that I will be talking about
today one of the many that we work on as
Tony said I've had the pleasure of
working with the practitioners at
Central Park and a lot of the interest
that I initially get is we have a
problem how can you help us and then
laws get passed that says well you can't
use those things anymore you can't have
those pesticides anymore and so then not
only do you become as I am an extension
scientists where you sort of help them
solve short-term issues they begin to
see the long-term challenges they're
going to face as the people who think
much of this is their front yard and
most of these people have a fair amount
of affluence to draw upon affluence and
influence to draw upon to impact the way
this particular landscape gets managed
so I spend a lot of time on the
intersection of managing plants
in urban environments and as Jenny a
gown if and said in her presentation in
our department meeting this morning the
sort of socio-economic intersection and
understanding how much people are
involved in the decisions and the way
things get managed out in these
landscapes and one of the driving forces
believe it or not in the urban landscape
is mimicry there's a fair amount of
research that's been conducted now to
say well if they see that's the way the
landscape is going to be that's what
everybody wants we know it in for neck
you know sort of common vernacular as
keeping up with the joneses right I
think we've observed this for a long
time and one of the problems is once one
person does it badly then you've got it
multiplied on and also so I'll show you
a pretty large scale the other thing
that's important to understand about the
urban environment particularly from a
stormwater perspective where I really
spend a lot of my time thinking about
reducing inputs because of these reasons
is eighty percent of the u.s. population
lives on about ten percent of the land
and the urban environments have a put
except put exceptional pressure on the
ecosystems that service them that most
of the time are not in cities bringing
the urban green infrastructure into the
city now begins to connect this
population with an ecosystem that can
service them for their needs but
oftentimes they put a disproportionate
pressure on those ecosystems that are
very much dispersed from where they are
so lots of interest in the urban
landscape rebuilding it building more
and of course all the roles that the
stormwater management system impacts
this grass is involved in it we cover a
fair amount of the landscape this is
from a 2005 NASA publication bimal SE
and others where they did some spectral
scans of the United States to look at
where grass was and by no surprise grass
is where the people are you don't see a
lot of grass out here that people
our managing as turf there's a lot of
grass out here I assure you I've seen it
but most of what we call managed turf is
managed in these urban environments and
that happens to be in close proximity
where we pave a lot of places right you
use all the sudden now eliminate a big
component of stormwater management in
fact make a lot of problems worse
because where people are there's also
going to be significant amounts of
impervious surface so the anything that
potentially goes on to that landscape if
it is allowed to escape into those
impervious surfaces then gets channeled
and funneled and concentrated into some
of the other issues that this wonderful
picture I saw on Twitter the other day I
couldn't help myself but steal it the
connectedness of the watersheds and the
rivers that connect our American
continental United States society and
you know when you start looking up in
here I actually wouldn't be surprised if
at some point we start to see laws drawn
along the lines of these watersheds as
they do throughout Europe so these kinds
of connected this connective tissue in
the in the water system is what I
connect myself to in the urban
environment so now that's ultimately
going to impact it be impacted by the
inputs that we bring into this urban
environment and what do people use in
urban environments well to the tune of
about five and a half billion dollars
they spend on lawn and garden products
this is an enormously large economic
driver in the green industry and if you
look just that pesticides and
fertilizers that could potentially have
nutrient and other health effects you
know you're looking at in excess of
fifty percent of all the money is spent
on stuff that gets put on that landscape
that even if we did sort of crude
percentage losses in the point 0 0 0 1
percentage points you're still looking
at enormous amounts of materials that
can concentrate and get into the water
and of course when you look at pesticide
use specifically New York State's been
keeping records for a number of years
and when you look at the pounds of
pesticides by County which is the way
the Dec has been collecting them for
many years you see that some of the
largest pesticide use gets associated in
the urban areas right Buffalo Rochester
Syracuse up the Hudson Valley into
Albany so lots of pesticide use in urban
areas and you know lots of rural areas
not as much right even though we know
there's a lot of agricultural production
going on there so if you wonder why
someone would be talking about pesticide
use on a golf course or in urban areas
there's enormous there's an enormous
amount of pesticide used in those areas
now is all of it on lawns probably not i
would say a lot of this could be and is
probably related in urban areas to
structural pest control i don't want to
say all of this is getting blanketed on
terrific golf courses but for sure
pesticides are a part of our lives which
is very disconnected from the way I
think many of our citizens view
pesticides well they don't use
pesticides but they don't look under the
counter and see the raid and the tick on
the detik material on their dogs which
is the same grub control we use for
lawns there's a enormous disconnect
where the stuff ends up tends to be a
big problem and so my approach to this
has always been pollution prevention
right if we're not using it if we're not
relying on it the chance that the usgs
is going to find it in a stream and
oddly enough when you see some of their
highest insecticide concentrations they
tend to be located at least in the
Northeast in some of these heavily
urbanized areas now we're not immune to
this from the nutrient perspective this
is the North and South Fork of Long
Island where if they've done some recent
nutrient use and testing well survey
surface and groundwater well surveys and
have found that you know fertilizers on
lawns and golf courses because of the
high percentage of golf courses and
lawns in these affluent areas there's a
fair amount of materials used and there
have been legislative initiative
in these areas to further restrict the
use of these nutrients so we've been
challenged as scientists to be able to
say well how can you justify this use so
my colleague and retired colleague Marty
Petrovic spent a lot of his career
working on this particular issue but the
pesticide issue is continues to the
restriction of pesticide use continues
to gather momentum in Tony's native land
of Canada one of your native lands of
Canada they've really led the charge in
banning pesticide use in urban
environments primarily on lawns but in
Montgomery County where this recent
legislation was promulgated and about to
be passed it was going to impact off
courses as well as especially municipal
golf courses one of the things that that
the people don't realize is a lot of
municipalities including the state of
New York manage golf as a recreational
landscape and so they provide
opportunities for laws to be passed that
don't have to be voted on by the
citizens if the governor signs an
executive order that's the way the parks
get managed that's the way the
municipalities get managed so what's
happening is they're trying to get some
of these executive orders at least on
public land now Montgomery County went a
little bit further and said we want to
ban it on private land as well now you
start running into the private public
land issues that we face in our country
Canada has gone one step further has
been the pmra it's been a very activist
organization since the new prime
minister came into power that
handsome-looking guy you got up there
and so chlorothalonil very commonly used
contact fungicide is going under
significant restrictions at bird I own
thio fan a methyl chlorpyrifos all of
these commonly used turf pesticides are
probably going to be completely removed
from the market in the next five to
seven years in Canada which I think
doesn't bode well for people who want to
sell chemicals in the United States
because I think that that is exactly the
way we are going to be going I've been
saying it for the better part of 25
years of my academic career so maybe by
the time I retire much of what I've been
barking about wine actually come true so
how do you deal with the public that you
when you ask them about environmental
issues how do they respond
so this is a couple of Gallup surveys I
wanted to make you aware of percentage
of Americans wearing a great deal about
certain environmental problems and two
of the ones that I work very closely
with drinking water and contamination of
soil water not necessarily by toxic
waste but pollution of rivers as well
you can see a mount for the people who
worry about environmental issues which
is about half about half of the American
population a full half of them are very
much worried about the things that our
work focuses on you know how do we keep
these inputs out of those water bodies
now the fascinating thing about the way
people view the environment is when the
economy is not doing well over the last
two decades since we've started to see
more significant financial crises and
you can track the financial crises on
this graph this is a simple question
that says if push comes to shove should
we favorite economic issues over
environmental issues or should we face
environmental issues over economic
issues and for many many years up until
the turn of the century they said wait a
minute protection of the environment
should be given priority over everything
right now you think while we're
experiencing this big environmental
movement but I think what you see is a
steady decline in people interested in
environmental quality certainly at the
level that they're interested in the
quality of their economic life so this
creates a number of challenges when
you're constantly talking to people
about environmental issues whether
they're going to be interested in what
you're selling what's saying whether it
whether there is a driver to motivate
them to change their behavior by using
less products and I think a lot of that
goes back to the sort of socio-economic
stuff that jenny was talking about in
our faculty meeting this morning and and
this SCAF really depicts that so I'm as
an extension scientist it's sort of nice
to learn new things but as I learn new
things I want to see how I can help
change people's behavior by taking that
science and and putting it to work and
that's really the stage I'm trying to
set move them forward so here's this
here's the issue this is the issue i was
on faculty couple years when this happen
Spitzer signs an executive order banning
pesticide use on state park land so in
1998 he comes in for the five minutes he
was governor and really sort of went
through and in his normal way sort of
slashed and burned everything and took a
real activist agenda and banned
pesticide use on state park land and at
the same time so did Suffolk County
Parks now what I thought was interesting
was what about the 27 New York State
Office of park recreation and historical
preservation courses that's what that
long acronym stands for what about those
courses and what about the three courses
on Long Island and I think they just
wrote he's a state parks we don't need
pesticides out of state park so the
state parks don't use roundup anymore
they don't use any synthetic chemical
pesticides that when there's not a golf
course associated with it so Jennifer
grant who many of you know dr. Jennifer
grant is the director of the New York
State IPM program we've been colleagues
since really already knew or even when I
was a graduate student here in the late
1980s when she was worked beginning her
work with rod farentino and I p.m. and
Jennifer came and said look what's
happening can we have golf courses
without pesticides I said no you can't
have a golf course without pesticides
and she said how do you know and that's
how dead silent the conversation went
after that no one's ever tested trying
to manage a golf course without
pesticides people say organic otherwise
I can promise you they're using regular
chemical pesticides and these executive
orders said anything with an EPA number
can't be used that was the executive
order that was signed when we first
started this work so she said how do you
know and so then it was writing
proposals and the normal process we go
through and you know the question was
simply at first we pitched the idea to
do it on our research plots because as a
practical golfcourse guy I said who's
going to let us kill grass on their golf
course because I'm was fairly sure that
was what was going to happen
ecologically if you are maintaining a
golf course for 70 years with pesticides
and all of a sudden you stop spraying
those pesticides what kind of chance you
think ecologically those plants have
that have been held up all
these years by preventing diseases and
preventing insect problems the problem
chances of them working are very less so
I blame Jennifer for me being here today
and of course my relationship with her
has been one of the great joys of my
career I had been fortunate to start
working with the bethpage Park guys on
the center of Long Island training them
because they had it was announced back
in 1997 that they were going to have the
2002 US Open which was the biggest golf
tournament in the world and they didn't
have a staff that even knew the first
thing about how they might prepare a
golf course for that they were state
park workers and this golf course which
is one of the great ones in the world
was left to into decline its demise and
decline was well known there just wasn't
money to keep it up the they wanted to
the leaders of golf want it to sort of
rien still public off so this was the
first time the US Open was held on a
truly public off course the kind of golf
course you sleep in your car to be able
to play first thing in the morning and
so I had this long relationship with
them and I literally will tell you i
leveraged it I said to the park
superintendent Dave Catalano at the time
I said hey man we need you have five
golf courses here we need one of them to
test this out and he said absolutely
that's what we should be doing it almost
gets me choked up every time I say it
because if he said no I'm not sure what
I would have done so he gave us the golf
course they basically said yeah do what
you got to do so 2002 bethpage was a
great place to do it because the world
was looking at bethpage right the world
had their eyes on this golf course that
hadn't been on television ever had never
hosted a major tournament and it had to
be sort of pulled off in a five-year
period and as you see it was enormously
successful even got to work with my
nephew was on the ground screw so one of
the things to do as an extension
scientist in my world is when there's
work to be done and there's a chance to
get up and do it it's a way you build
relationships with your peers as say hey
least not just a guy who locks himself
up in those rooms he's out there
actually boy knows how to run a greens
mower he knows how to do this he knows
how to do that
I do because before I came back to
graduate school I was a golf course
superintendent but I want to say how
much of a benefit this is in changing
people's behavior I think one of the
great challenges environmental groups
have in general is they're trying to
change systems many times from the
complete outside and I am I don't know
how else to say it I'm a mole I'm this
guy who's been in the turf business for
thirty something years and have
consistently tried to make changes in
this environmental way and I finally
after 25 years I feel like some of that
work is coming to fruition so this is
what work is like during a US open when
it rains a lot that's me you wouldn't
believe they actually try to play golf
in this thing they even wrote a book
about the tournament I'm mentioned a
couple of times in this book was the
first time again the big tournament was
played on a public stage all right
bethpage is a busy place people love
playing golf they'll play between 50 and
60 thousand 18-hole rounds a year on the
green course that we work that we play
on it's not uncommon that when you play
God at the golf course here this is one
of the putting greens so here's a group
putting their ball in this group here
finished putting and is waiting for
these guys to tee off who are teeing off
while there's people on the green it's a
par three so they're hitting to the
green while people on the par-3 are
standing back waiting for them to head
up that's what this is like it is a
constant play traffic and all that foot
traffic creates a lot of challenges for
living things of which grass plants are
mode at about a tenth of an inch when
they're experiencing that traffic so
what is the bethpage state park it's
five golf courses 1,500 acres 260
thousand rounds across the five golf
courses only 35,000 on the championship
course it's second only to the parking
lot at Niagara Falls and income for the
state park system nothing makes more
money than the parking lot at Niagara
Falls and Beth blades is typically a
close second to it our work is being
done on the green course we didn't
necessarily think about that at the time
but the green course that was the
original golf course that was on the
land when Robert Moses bought and bought
is loose term for Robert Moses he sort
of said I want it and next thing you
know he had it and so then they built
out the golf course to include five
other properties as well so our work was
on the green course now i want to just
set the stage for the first part of the
study because the meat of it is actually
the second part of the work that we've
been doing in the last seven years so
for the first ten years 13 years we were
conducting an experiment that was a
systems-based trial and i guess the
easiest way to explain it is when you go
on a diet as a person sometimes nowadays
there actually are prescribed foods but
generally you can eat lots of different
things Weight Watchers has a point
system you get these many points for
this food and so they'll tell you
exactly what to eat all time but they
say here's what that stuff has to be
like that's how I would describe the way
we approach the work we have 18 putting
surfaces which is where we wanted to do
this work we put nine of them under you
know what you're normally doing on the
golf course and nine of them under what
we thought would be practices that
reduce overall stress on the plants and
maximize their ability to withstand
pests pressure if they're under less
stress theoretically they'll be less
exposed less vulnerable to particularly
fungal diseases fungal pathogens insect
predation are the two big pest problems
on these playing surfaces so we had nine
the way they were doing it and nine the
way we thought they should do it in the
future and then within those nine
surfaces we replicated three pest
management approaches one that they
normally used one that we would call a
sort of progressive IPM approach and one
that initially initially was following
the executive order no chemicals with an
EPA number then I'll show you in a
minute why we have to adapt
that particular treatment to ultimately
become what we published as bio-based
pest management biologicals reduced risk
products that the EPA indicates as such
and so we did we published a paper in
our international turfgrass research
journal back in 2009 that summarized our
first seven years of work and I don't
expect you to pay attention to the suite
of practices I just want you to see that
these were what the cultural management
systems look like when i say cultural
management it's how you mow how you
fertilize how you water these are
enormously intensive management systems
enormous amounts of intervention on a
daily basis this is gonna put the apple
tree and see you in 30 years kind of
thing this is every day they're at it
doing something to these playing
surfaces on a variety of different ways
to condition them to perform the way
they're supposed to so what we often
call the most dysfunctional building in
the entire state of New York that's the
state house so the goals of our original
project as we set it out was the first
how do we if you ban pesticides what are
these growers going to do they don't
have there was no one's ever sort of
said how do you do this with one hand
tied behind your back those questions
had never really been asked before so we
said wait a minute we need to figure out
what sorts of things work and give
policymakers an opportunity to see the
work we would invite them out on a
regular basis during the study to say
hey here's the treatment that you the
law you would just are about to impose
this is going to be what happens when
everybody starts managing like this and
so this is the funeral service for the
second putting surface on the green
course it didn't take long for this to
happen the first two years we made it
into two July one year in early August
another year and then basically within a
week that's what happens and they died
from the most commonly found fungal
pathogen that no one ever were
about the disease that actually began
came in and killed these surfaces is one
that Nolan even if you ask people are
the top ten problems they barely make
that top ten list it's so common that
they just spray all the time for it and
never think about and all of a sudden
when you don't have the tools that solve
common problems and you don't have
alternatives to those problem
alternatives to solve those issues it
becomes very difficult to not have
surfaces like this these were putting
surfaces that been managed with
chemicals in various ways shapes or form
all the way back to chlordane in the 30s
these greens had never seen these putty
surfaces had never seen a growing season
without regular pesticide use so when we
stopped doing it two years in a row this
is what happened that's why the final
treatment that that bio-based sorry the
bio-based pest management here at the
bottom had to be implemented because
Dave can Alanna looked at us and said do
you have to keep killing these greens
are you learning something if you're
learning something by continuing to kill
them by all means continue to kill them
but if you're not learning anything
maybe you can stop and we did one more
thing before we softened that's we
invited the policy makers out there the
Suffolk County legislators we probably
had four there and we had two state
senators and their aides there for the
Twilight field day with about 15-20
people and we said this is what happens
when your law gets enacted and their
comment was oh I I think that there is
this and maybe you see this in
agriculture as well there's this
pervasive attitude what do you need
pesticides for how hard is how r could
it be what do you need pesticides for it
and oh it's a golf course why are you
using them on a golf course so the idea
that we would take away a tool and it
would result in something like this I
think speaks to the level of ignorance
that we have in much of our legislators
when it comes to these kinds of
complicated issues so our operating
principles with the project was number
one established cultural practices that
reduce stress create an environment that
has less problems and then when you're
going to intervene with a product right
I can tell you every snake oil salesman
in the country found out we were doing
this and said hey we got the magic
potion for you Frank and we had to
immediately say wait a minute who says
that and they said well you know we
tried it in a greenhouse one weekend on
cucumber and it worked really good so so
that's the kind of stuff that we were
confronted with when we started this
work you know 15 years ago so challenges
of new technology i will say you know
god bless those people at bethpage for
putting up with you know if I had 10
ideas one of them might have been a good
one but they let me try all 10 of them
and we tried brewery waste compost for
snow mold we had to push the snow off
and put the brewery ways down because
there was data that said that would work
and lo and behold we didn't have snow
mold but we had the worst case a fairy
ring you've ever seen this whole idea i
read a recent paper recently that a
paper recently that increasing
pseudomonads has led to more take all
patch problems in week a gal minomycin
species problem goes up when you
increase microbial activity of a
particular microbe so I think we have a
lot to learn about these sorts of things
in this drove many of the golf course
guys crazy this one year we have gone to
pharmaceutical grade microbial
fermenters put these bugs in the put the
microbes in there blew a slurry put it
in a spray tank and spray it every day
for a hundred and fifty days so we did
that and it was okay I mean it certainly
reduced some of the pest problems it was
a microorganism and that for a while
they were injecting this stuff into the
irrigation system but it just wasn't
practical we did the carbon footprint
that would have been better to bring a
hundred more pounds of pesticide into
the r into the operation then use this
thing we've tried direct injection
sprayers Andrew Landers when he first
came to campus have worked with us on
this it's a pure tank of water with
jockey tanks that it will allow you in
real
time to adjust rates and locations and 2
a 2 full boom set up this was a
state-of-the-art prototype once we had
an intern that used it once that kid
left everybody looked at it said I'm not
sitting on that thing and agriculture
has been doing this for a really long
time and now it's finally starting to
come back to the golf industry GPS
controlled sprayers variable rate
technology I was 15 years ahead of my
time we had this on the golf course 15
years ago and we couldn't even get him
to take a look at it one student did it
one year and we could never get it going
again compost teas this was a big deal
with the organic movement on Long Island
we have a lot of very people with a lot
of time on their hands that really
believe organic is the solution to every
problem known to man and if we just use
more compost the world would be better
so we did the research in Ithaca and
found and then we actually did it on
Long Island as well to appease some of
these real critical people say they
didn't think we were doing anything
useful because it wasn't organic direct
injectors on the side of the irrigation
system we did this actually at the
cornell golf course as well products
that you find there's billions of
dollars spent on products that have no
practical value for use in turf no
matter what we say we can't stop them
from using them but they continue to do
it so just to give you a sense of the
golf course that we're talking about
fairly small putting surfaces about
4,500 square feet and they get a fair
amount of traffic I show you this graph
this was a seven-year track of the
rounds of golf this is what happened
after the first two years of kill and
greens so this is when we started and
then the greens died and they didn't
come back and then the greens died and
didn't come back and so once the state
revenue people said whoa make it less
money on this maybe there is something
to this golf course thing that we should
pay attention to and so we made some
adjustments to our systems that allowed
us that bio-based pest management and we
saw a return rounds of golf and one when
I show this to people who manage golf
courses has small businesses
many small farmers like oh yeah when our
greens are in good shape people don't
like playing here or they want a
discount and let me tell you how rude
Long Island Public offers can be
sometimes when they find they can't play
a putting green because it's dead they
want a discount on the round so anyway
speaking of the golfers we did interview
them regularly this was Jennifer's part
of the project dealing with the golfers
and so we would service them survey them
and ask them if percentage of golfers
had said they wanted you to keep quality
high use pesticides whenever they might
help keep reasonably good use pesticides
judiciously minimize pesticide use
regardless of quality and don't use
pesticides now what you see in this
graph that's fascinating is particularly
in the early parts of the study we
didn't show we didn't survey them when
the greens were dead necessarily but a
lot of these golfers went through this
experience you can see a starting an
occasional increase and when we started
looking at this data further there did
track economy the better the economy was
and the more they liked playing golf the
less they cared about pesticide use and
golfers in general don't care much about
pesticide use in general they have sort
of grown accustomed to it like people
who live in agrarian societies and see
farmers apply pesticides all the time
they don't see it as something abnormal
that people do but on golf course is you
know where people don't normally see
people other people applying pesticides
people who are not golfers get all
worked up about it we find that the
golfers tend not to get that worked up
about it okay so how would you rate the
overall condition of the green course in
2008 and so we had about a sixty percent
very good and twenty-eight percent
adequate so we're going to say tough New
York public golf crowd we've satisfied
about eighty-five percent ninety percent
of the public and we're driving down
pesticide use in this project so we
surveyed the golfers and we asked them
about how they thought it looked and how
they thought it played
so green quality rating by golfers
looking at our I p.m. with alternative
cultural practices all of them thought
those greens were good the can equal to
0 statistically the same as the way
they've been doing business so we've
developed this alternative collection of
practices that the golfers say is doing
pretty good and consistent with the way
they've been doing business in the past
so if we can make our adjustments to
their management good for the
environment and transparent to the
golfer that's the sweet spot that I
think we were suited for when we started
this work and playing surfaces as well
it can skip over some of that we
monitored labor hours because one of the
knocks on alternative or organic is it
takes more time it's more labor
intensive and we did not necessarily
find that now the AC is alternative
culture I p.m. and the green bar is the
standard practice the blue bar is the
progressive practices that we've
implemented and you could see early on
when we first started implementing them
it took more time right changing the way
they manage you'd expect things that
take more time but as we've gone along
we saw that oh they got used to this
different way of management and then it
no longer took more time than the
conventional approach now fundamentally
the title of my talk is pesticide use
reduction so let me talk to you about
the way we look about pesticide use
obviously practitioners pick them based
on multiple factors Jennifer likes
efficacy economics and the environment I
think it's an easy way to summarize the
way people select pesticides we have
Cornell guidelines that guides them but
I'll approach with at bethpage and then
with our larger state park group has
been first of all New York State labeled
chemicals it's got to be labeled for use
in New York that's the use of the
guidelines we want it to be effective
and I'll show you how we went about that
and we wanted to introduce some sort of
environmental screening that said okay
here's 10 pesticides they're different
chemically they're different based
their potential environmental impact we
want you to screen the products you use
based on this screening model known to
many as the environmental impact
quotient so before I get to a discussion
at the eiq I want to give you a sense
there's an enormous amount of data
available looking at efficacy of
products land grant institutions have no
problem spraying plots have no problem
telling you what works and doesn't work
and they do such a good job of it I
don't have to do it we don't have to do
it and I can use that information and
translate it here and paul Vance elia
proud Cornell grad at Kentucky publishes
a particular bulletin every year that
ranks efficacy looks at fungicide to
mattify tests and says these do pretty
well in a lot of different studies these
do poorly in a lot of different studies
these do good and some not good in
others and so he ranks the efficacy of
the various products so we've put this
into a tool to help the managers make
decisions now the IQ is one you may be
aware of djokovic a former fruit I p.m.
specialist developed this model many
years ago to see if he could compare
organic apple production to I p.m. apple
production to conventional apple
production that was the original intent
of this model that he began to run
chemicals through to demonstrate one
pest management system versus another
this model is heavily scrutinized by the
scientific communities one person Paul
was the paper said it's no better than
random numbers now i will say there are
some caveats to this when the model was
originally developed there was a lot of
products that were really bad we were
using and i think one of the things
that's affected its efficacy as a model
of screening is a lot of those products
are gone so the wide disparity and
potential environmental impact of a lot
of products is more related to their
overall amounts then necessarily their
their inherent toxicity so this fancy
this model that Joe developed jennifer
and I sat down said hey we should give
these guys a tool at bethpage to screen
these things we adapted this a little
bit for our use and then began to have
them use it so this was
table that a turf manager would get at
bethpage for a dollar spot control a
score of tinea minor that common disease
that killed those greens here's a
variety of products that we know have
decent efficacy the frack code for those
of you that aren't familiar with these
action codes is at a track code and iraq
code this is the frack code fungicide
resistance action committee that
basically codes them based on their mode
of action we want it to stop using a
particular compact fungicide called
chlorothalonil and a lot of the concern
was all we're going to get resistance to
these other chemicals as well you're
going to get resistance of all you do is
spray one particular type of chemical
but if you use a variety of modes of
action you're more likely to hold off
resistance resistance management
continues to be and is emerging issue in
our field as well so this is what they
have and the subsequent eiq numbers that
go along with it we encourage them to
use reduce risk products we encourage
them when ft wizzy was there to use Omri
listed products and we've used a few and
then we looked at the eiq of the various
management systems so a set i don't know
i don't know how i don't expect you to
grab all this but essentially what i
want you to do is compare this one to
this one coat this is conventional
culture conventional pest management and
what you see here is what we were
learning in these other pest management
programs these bio-based ones treatment
integrity was compromised a little bit
and they started using them in their
conventional treatment so we were not
the best research result but a really
good behavior will change like wow this
product works as good as that product
this one's better for the environment
I'll use that product my sense is if you
give growers options that they can
afford and that work most likely they're
going to use those approaches if it's
not a big shift in their system so we
see real this is the one I want you to
compare to not this one alternative
culture and I p.m. versus conventional
culture and can
national pest management and so you see
the real low E IQ which is indicating
the environmental impact is
significantly reduced so another way of
looking at the same data which
culminated in a publication that Bob
Portman so we lost unexpectedly this
past March we're sorry to lose Bob we
didn't just lose him from here Bob
passed away suddenly so it was a big
shock to our program but this was his
master's work and a longtime colleague
with mine so once we got that data we
hired Bob and we said hey we learn this
stuff out at the on the green course how
about we take it to the whole state park
system apply the same thinking and
started to look at our eiq for our pest
management programs and compare them to
different golf courses we were
collecting pest management programs
pesticide use records from around the
country comparing what some golf courses
are doing compared to what our flagship
golf course the tournament golf course
was doing and the average state golf
courses were doing so first of all we
were starting to establish a baseline
now the University of Wisconsin has
taken this and they're creating a
statewide initiative of all their golf
courses to be at or below an average eiq
value but one of the things you notice
these are various parts of the golf
course small area so this is about this
represents about three acres this is
about four acres fairways generally can
be 20 to 30 acres of turf rough areas 40
to 60 acres so the more you apply
pesticides to larger areas the larger
your eiq goes up and I've been still
comfortable using the eiq because while
it's a measure of toxicity of the
material risk is a function of toxicity
and exposure so we're looking at the
toxicity of the product and the exposure
that a golfer or the citizens might have
by deploying these compounds on a large
area so when we look so now you're
looking at seven years one two three
four five six years of data we've
collected from
15 state park golf courses that have
been participating in the expanded
program since 2009 2010 and this is the
total environmental impact of their
pesticide use over that period of time
so you can see when we started the
program this was the year before we
started we started the program he said
hey use this list spray less compound uz
IQ and boom right away we saw big
reductions now I break this out into all
the golf courses or 15 courses only the
five or six on Long Island no seven on
Long Island and then eight upstate so
seven and eight golf course is so
roughly the same number of golf courses
but you see the majority of pesticide
use is occurring on long island golf
courses right on long island golf
courses so they immediately began to
drop their eiq and they got pest
problems like crazy once we started to
take this out to a broader audience they
were going through the same thing we
went through when we started 15 years
ago now what I think we've seen is sort
of a return we watched a big increase
for a couple of years in Jennifer grant
and I worked very closely on training
and trying to figure this out and so in
the last few years we've implemented a
strategy that I want to leave you with
as I wrap up what we've learned in these
last few years about really changing
pest management behavior using this data
so what this data allows us to do and
what Bob really left us this great gift
is this enormous database that allows us
to look at their behavior based on
environmental impact of the products
that they used so we took the field use
eiq which is the toxicity the material
calibrated for the rate multiplied by
the area treated so you see that a
majority of increases across this is all
15 golf courses came from large
increases to rough areas weed control it
was the primary product that's driving a
lot of this as well as additional
fungicide treatments that are getting
made because once people see a really
good golf course they want to keep
playing on a really good golf course
once you give them a perfect Apple
they want a perfect Apple all the time
so we've sort of were a victim of our
own success that we got good at it and
we watch their behavior so he said wait
a minute we're going to start to stop
this so we started to make some changes
there you also see fairway use which was
high as has gotten bigger and yeah and
pine green use is stayed fairly flat
this is where it got very interesting
and where we've really implemented the
education first of all we want you to
stop you we told the guys we wanted to
stop using products that are very high
toxicity and it represented in 2015
about fifty percent of the products they
were still using we would call bad
actors or e I Q's above a value that we
liked you're starting to see a decline
in their use but boy that use went up
quite a bit even above where we started
this is where the education has been
focused most recently and that is to
pest problems on these golf courses that
50 that about 50% forty-eight percent of
all the pesticide used on these 15 golf
courses went at these two pests and
that's what this aiq data allowed us to
see so again we tried to eat knowing
this we tried to implement some training
which included the use of predictive
models skipped be over this the use of
predictive models that was saying that
we've been working with rt gaetano at
the Northeast climate Center we had
these predictive models available for
the last decade so we started using
these models a long time ago and develop
risks that could predict when this
disease would be a particular problem
and we asked the practitioners to
monitor that data so here you have these
dots and low medium and high risk put
out in indices so here is below this is
low-risk medium risk for disease high
risk for disease and this is the trace
of the risk that was experienced at
bethpage in 2014
you can see there was about a 12 to 14
day period when risks were very high
that's when we want to reserve those
high-risk control products for only
those times and use softer products or
products with lower IQ values during
periods of lower risk if they're needed
at all so we began this in 2014 gave
them some suggestions for looking at a
model what would happen and then
actually looked at their chemical
applications during that period of time
and found when you look at their eiq
values that one I don't know what
happened there but when you look at some
of their yo highest ew q values they're
following when some of the pressures
were the highest so we're starting to
see that by bringing a lot of different
ways of thinking about pest management
to bear for these people they're
starting to adjust their management to
be more in line with when the risk
occurs how to use these lower eiq
products and how the result in the end
is going to be less environmental risk
associated with pesticide use Andy
Wilson is our project manager and
deserves all the credit in the world for
putting up with me all these years of
visiting I would spend every other I was
down on Long Island from april to
november every other week for the better
part of seven years and he put up with
me this was at the most recent Barclays
tournament we've shifted some of our
work to enhance pollinator habitat the
project continues to expand we get a
hundred thousand dollars every year from
state parks and we've started to plant
some of these out of way areas now into
places where pollinators have some more
help and of course our most recent
extension accomplishment was publishing
this new york state best management
practices for golf courses this is
primarily for water quality protection
and the eiq and the things that we've
learned from our project are embedded in
this so with that I'm right at my time
sorry for that wish I had time for
questions
one or two quick questions yes city or
two and one was try to turn and the
other is our they're known as impressive
loyalty to the fungal diseases you're
interested in Ian could you use of like
a microbiome transplant type of book
been approached to try to enhance so the
answer to the first question did you
strike a derma the answer is yes and we
continued to use to try to turn long our
product down there it's worked very well
on a number of root pathogen problems
that we've had as far as suppressing
soils no such luck there Janice we I
think everything else in early on in his
career was working on that particular
area I think we found some things with
the pity of that might be useful but I
don't think anybody's taking that work
any further I know that's something that
the microbiome is James working on and
then ad future for that sort of stuff we
haven't found any suppressant soils that
we can characterize that exists car one
more question anybody had last question
all right if not let's fight
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu